thank you
this was designed to demand attention
[Music]
the Roar of cutting-edge Chinese fighter
jets
top secret for so long now displayed for
the public for the world to see
[Music]
China's national air show is a
celebration of all things Aviation from
the more basic to the battle ready a
highly militarized display at a time
when the world increasingly fears what
this military could do amongst the crowd
we met UA gun he served for over 20
years in the Chinese armed forces and
has seen firsthand how it's changed what
message do you think this Air Show sends
to the rest of the world about China's
military capabilities
and that could include interests here in
Taiwan the self-governing island China
Seas as its own the British trade
minister is meeting the president during
a visit this week and it seems to have
drawn a response
fighter jets exactly like these are
increasingly flying towards the island
things more tense than they've been in
some time
the number of these jets that has
crossed the unofficial Maritime border
with Taiwan in just the last few days is
the highest it's been in months it is
unusual to be allowed to see them so
close and the message from China is
clear this is a modernized military
absolutely able to fight an
international War if needed
and an international war is possible if
China ever did attack inside there were
simulations of how an island Invasion
could look but many who came to observe
were still cautious
there is a real pride in the military
here but the idea of controlling Taiwan
could well be more popular than War
either way tensions feel like they're
headed firmly in One Direction China is
telling the world it's ready
Helen Ann Smith Sky News in juhai
southern China